okay so this is our kitchen um
we have enough food i mean here's fresh
food
and then we still have some uh
in the fridge we still have some
meat
and in the
fridge we still have some
vegetables and
noodles also
plus
some
rice over here and other stuff plus some
canned food but the canned food we're
not
willing to uh to use yet because we
don't know how long we're gonna be uh be
here
plus uh in the kitchen you can see we're
quite serious about protecting ourselves
so
we put a
bag with water to uh close up this uh
close of the sink because we don't know
if the infections are coming from here
okay so this is our window and then
in the morning the sunlight is on here
so that's the only sunlight sort of
freedom we can get put a pillow here and
then sit in the
in the windowsill
and then look outside
that's that's our freedom there's
positive cases in our compound all
around and also inside our building now
second floor third floor fifth floor um
so it's a little bit nervous situation
because first we risk the chance of
infection getting ill but also maybe
more extreme is getting removed from
your house and putting put into a
quarantine center
people are posting the
self-test in in the wechat group but
also some tests are hidden and then some
some people have tested positive and
then two days later they test negative
and we're not sure and neighbors are not
sure if that's true because self-tests
are very easy to manipulate
um so
trust has been uh
influenced a little bit trust is running
low stress is running very high
we're doing okay on food
um
doing okay on everything except this
security and the safety of being
infected i think nobody really prepared
for this long and i think every
household is running into a different
problem i think there's a neighbor here
they run out of printer inked so this
parent cannot print uh his kids homework
so how is how's the kid going to do
homework now
there's
laundry
soap
shampoo toothpaste toilet paper but we
do see that even compounds that have
been locked for several weeks there are
still new infections suddenly coming out
of nowhere
so it's very difficult to contain
it's also very demotivating for the
people that live there because they have
been locked down for three weeks no
cases and then suddenly there is a case
nobody knows really how
and but this also means that uh yeah
when this is going to end in normal
times the security guard and the
neighborhood committee they decide where
to throw away your garbage or where to
park your car
very simple things but now suddenly
they're deciding about who can go to
hospital or what happens with a dog if
the owner tests positives
they're not really prepared or educated
for this
and that's and that has caused a lot of
problems we do a little bit of support
but the apartment is like 20 square
meter so we tried walking around but
then use after 2000 steps to get dizzy
can do some uh we have these water
barrels so we can do some lifting or uh
partners yoga regardless of whether a
zero coverage
or letting it go uh whether which
strategy is applied
i think some res storm uh procedures
have been too strict such as separating
kids from parents that has changed now
but also removing people from from their
own homes that's very extreme measure
and
i think there were some people also in
china speaking out against this some
very prominent people but they've all
been censored i'm sure a lot of experts
will leave there are wechat groups going
around and with tips i'll do how to get
a plane ticket how to order a taxi to
the
airport
so there's gonna
a lot of experts gonna leave um i don't
have this plan but
uh um i just hope that china finds a
good way to
coexist with this virus or to
to achieve zero copy